说话人 1: 什么是美式口
说话人 1: 简单来说就是一个美式的口角，非常的瑟琴，非常的爽的那种口角，就看这个妹子接不接这个话了
说话人 1: 这个时候我给出了一个绝杀，我说你确实算是一个合格的跑友，值得欣赏的女人
说话人 1: 我又消除了评判系统，我又进了一个
说话人 1: 你好，我是Jackson，今天给兄弟们带来一个给女人上疗，非常短期的一个妹子，同时也是直接到妹子家里去收尾的这样一个案例，你们可以在这里
说话人 1: 节课中看到非常多的前沟通的短期的一些操作，非常的细致，非常的灵敏，好好学习，兄弟们
说话人 1: 我们先来看一下这个案例的一个背景情况，OK，这个兄弟说是一个高中生，经常给他主动发消息，这代表是一个绿灯，对吧
说话人 1: 但是他不是一个大绿灯，只是给他发消息，仅此而已
说话人 1: 而且在我们后面的情况来看，这个兄弟在前面聊的东西都是非常浅的，他前面大概聊了十几页的一个聊天，这里不给大家放出来
说话人 1: 聊的话题都是一些很，一些很无关紧要的一些话题，就是一些废话
说话人 1: 主要的升级在我这里几个回合已经直接给他升到很高的位置
说话人 1: 这个兄弟把案例丢在群里，他没给出目的，这里我问他说出你的目的
说话人 1: 兄弟们可以看一下，OK，女生的短期属性，其实这个兄弟没有去把它激发出来，就是聊的一些很浅的一些话题，简单看一下
说话人 1: 我们来到第一个回合，这个时候我接手了，因为在前面这个兄弟聊的比较长期，女生听起来也很长期，这个时候我要做一个试探，这个女生到底是长期还是短期
说话人 1: 但是我会尽量想把它往短期方向聊，因为这样更容易让这个兄弟去收尾
说话人 1: 所以说我回了一句，我不喜欢经验少的
说话人 1: 那么这一句话是什么样的一个意思
说话人 1: 它其实是一个试探，它不代表这个女生要是短期，或者说是长期，我只是把这句话当一个刺拳一样给它丢出去，然后看女生怎么去反应这句话
说话人 1: 我会接下来去测后面的一个窗口，后面的一个长短区属性，这是一个比较高超的一个技巧，就是试探
说话人 1: 然后兄弟们看妹子的回复，她说哦
说话人 1: 喜欢老司机呗，我发了一个表情
说话人 1: 很多兄弟，包括这个兄弟，他可能都会慌，可能都会开始慌，因为女生说啊，喜欢老司机呗，什么什么，你以为她是在推你，对吧
说话人 1: 你以为她不喜欢这样的一个东西，所以说你们可能马上就会舔上去，如果说你们回复的话，你们可能会说啊，不是喜欢老司机，我比较喜欢少女，我比较喜欢纯洁的，对吧
说话人 1: 你马上就会怂掉，这个时候不能怂，我们要测试一下她这句话的一个真假，知道吧
说话人 1: 因为我看出是没有明显的一个抗拒的
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 因为我的社交直觉比较灵敏，我的经验比较多，我能看出这句话，她是不怎么抗拒的，所以说我会接下来继续选择进攻
说话人 1: 到了这个回合，我让这个兄弟回的是，至少不能像个海星
说话人 1: 妹子她就笑了，她说哈哈哈
说话人 1: 这个兄弟，他可能阅历比较少，他的经历比较少，他不明白我说的这句话是什么意思
说话人 1: 当时我是没理他的，因为我觉得去解释这样的东西很无聊，群里还有很多的兄弟在向我咨询，我还要继续回答别人的一个问题
说话人 1: 但是这个兄弟他还是在一直的追问我，我当时是没有理他，这个时候我继续选择进攻，因为女人的窗口是 OK 的，我说所以你是海星吗
说话人 1: 这个兄弟还是在追问，他说杰哥海星是什么意思
说话人 1: 我不懂这个东西
说话人 1: 这个兄弟他可能害怕，对吧
说话人 1: 他可能害怕这个东西是一个不好的东西，把女生给得罪了，他有多重的一个心理在攻击着他，所以我在这里要安慰一下这个兄弟，给这个兄弟解释一下，我说海星就是那种活很烂的意思，就是躺在床上像一个大的海星，一点不会动，像一个身体一样
说话人 1: OK，我把这个解释给到她
说话人 1: 在这里我要说一下，群里的兄弟们找我代聊的时候，不要问我太多无聊的一些问题，我发出来你们只管回复就行
说话人 1: 因为代聊这么长时间，你们都知道我的代聊非常的稳，非常的，有些时候你们只需要选择信任就行了
说话人 1: 然后女生这个时候回了，不是吧，发了一个吃瓜的表情
说话人 1: 兄弟们看到这样的回复，以为女生是不好的窗口，女生是不好的反应，对吧
说话人 1: 但是不是，女生为什么会发这种吃瓜的表情
说话人 1: 然后会发这种很平的一个语气
说话人 1: 我给兄弟们分析一下，因为他不确定你这个人是不是真的在聊骚，是不是真的是有那么短期的属性，他怕你去评判他，他害怕这样的一个东西，所以说
说话人 1: 才做出这样的一个平淡反应
说话人 1: 为什么会出现这样的情况
说话人 1: 是因为这个兄弟在之前聊的非常的长期，聊的非常的乖，所以说到这个时候会有一致性的断裂，就突然变得比较有进攻性，会让这个女生觉得太奇怪，这个时候我们就要去操作处理一下这个东西
说话人 1: 这个时候我做了一个消除评判，然后把女生拉回的一个操作，我说这点算是加分的，然后立刻我又接了一个进攻，又接了一个进攻，我说会哪些
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是问她会哪些姿势
说话人 1: 但是这个兄弟他看漏了呀，他没有把这个意思给打出去，所以说女生只吃到了我的一半的攻击
说话人 1: 女生给出了一个假性的一个无兴趣指标，她就说你要求挺高的呀，发了一个尴尬的表情
说话人 1: 这个兄弟可能这个时候又开始慌了，我让他继续把那句发出去，会哪些姿势
说话人 1: 这会给到女生什么样的一种感觉
说话人 1: 就是你在她的脑子里面已经开始操她了，已经有了非常强的性张力，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这就是一个有艺术性的聊天
说话人 1: 有艺术性的聊较高阶的聊骚的玩法，你们可以体验一下这文字里面的力量
说话人 1: 这个时候女生说了，她说比如说呢，是哪些姿势
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我识别到可以来一把比较强大的一个进攻性
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们是不敢发这样的话的，因为他们，第一，他们判断不了窗口，对吧
说话人 1: 他们不敢发这样的话
说话人 1: 第二，他们本身不敢发这样的很强烈的一个攻击性，害怕女人给搞砸，害怕女人骂他，害怕女人喷他
说话人 1: 但是我的社交直觉给到我的经验就是，这一次升级会非常大的一个
说话人 1: 概率成功
说话人 1: OK，所以说我做出了这样的事情，你们不要模仿，但是你们可以去体验这里面的一个操作
说话人 1: 这个时候我直接给这个兄弟发了一个美式口，这一句很骚的话给他发出去
说话人 1: 什么是美式口
说话人 1: 简单来说就是一个美式的口角，就是非常的瑟琴，非常的非常的爽的那种口角，就看这个妹子接不接这个话了，我们就可以把她推到一个很高的一个关系
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说不会
说话人 1: OK，只要女生回答了这个问题，不管她会还是不
说话人 1: 会，就已经成功了，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，因为他已经进入这个非常强烈的性氛围了，这个时候我还是选择继续进攻，因为没有明显的一个排斥反应，我就说就是拧毛巾的那种，兄弟们，这是一个什么样的一个描述方法
说话人 1: 它是一个未来画面的一个感觉，就是直接给到女生脑子里的一个画面，这比你的普通的聊天，一些文字的对局要高级的多，要深刻的多，知道吗
说话人 1: 你们一定要学习到这样的一个聊天方式，就是种植画面感
说话人 1: 一个好的小说家，一个好的语言表达的
说话人 1: 演讲家，他们都会给给所有的观众种植下一个画面，让他们更好的深刻的去理解，深刻的去沉浸，这就是语言的强大的威力
说话人 1: 这个时候，妹子说了个不了解，OK，她明显是没想入这个局，为什么还是前面的一致性断裂的原因，她现在骚不起来，就需要一些温度
说话人 1: 这个时候我做了一个拉回的操作，我说那会比较有野性，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是OK，那样是一个好的行为，它不是一种很瑟琴
说话人 1: 那是一种很OK，很棒的一个行为，在附和他，这会让他更加的变成我们想要的那种方式
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说，哦哦，是一个很平，对吧
说话人 1: 但是不重要，这个时候没有负反馈就行，不需要每次都有正反馈
说话人 1: 兄弟们可能在很多聊天里面看到一个负反馈，啊，这把糟了，看到一个正反馈，哇，这个太了
说话人 1: 不要不要这样，大局观放远一点，淡定一点，兄弟们，不要被一些聊天的假象给迷惑
说话人 1: 这个时候我说投入一点，什么意思
说话人 1: 有两层意思，第一层意思是让他在
说话人 1: 行哎中让她投入一点，美式口角这个行为，她是比较投入的，这能让她在以后收尾的时候更加的主动，为我们的性体验做准备
说话人 1: 第二个意思是让她在这个聊天里面投入一点，不要跟我来一些哦哦，一些哦哦，一些无聊的一些话，知道吗
说话人 1: 就是让她多给一些谈资出来
说话人 1: 这时候妹子吃进去了，她说怎么说呢
说话人 1: 具体详细一点，不太了解这一方面
说话人 1: OK，我们先不管她了不了解这些姿势，还是说她真的是一个长期
说话人 1: 这些都不重要，我们接下来还有牌去试探
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员给他发一个美式口角的视频，给这个女生发过去
说话人 1: 但是这个时候学员可能是怂了，可能是还
说话人 1: 害怕微信被封，对吧
说话人 1: 他可能对这方面不是很了解，所以说他没有发
说话人 1: 我给这个学员说，你去打一个码去发，但是他还是没有听
说话人 1: 他是后面私自编了一大段话给女人发过去，这段话其实造成了妹子的一个窗口下降，就是前面聊得非常的有进攻性，到了这里突然变怂了，这其实是会有一个下头，会有一个割裂感，非常的让人生气，这样的一个回复
说话人 1: 他后面还来问我，哦
说话人 1: Jackson，这个女生怎么不回复了
说话人 1: 我当时看到非常的生气，我把她骂了一顿，我说你加那么多话干嘛呢
说话人 1: 让你发个视频这么简单的事，去把它搞废了，解释一大堆，对吧
说话人 1: 又有表情，又，我算了，怕微信被封，又解释了很多文字方面的东西，又发了一个墨镜的表情，看起来非常的肥宅，看起来非常的屌丝
说话人 1: 说实话，这个女生窗口是很大，如果说是其他女生，光这段话就足以把这个聊天给废掉
说话人 1: 就足以把这个煮熟的鸭子都给搞飞，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，聊天是非常凶险的，有时候一个标点，一个表情都能暴露你的需求感
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员去拍了一下这个女生，看一下这个女生的一个窗口
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们在女生不回你的时候，隔了一段时间，大概 6 个小时，或者说多久，你可以再去试探一下，不要女生一不回你，这个女生不回我了，杰哥怎么办
说话人 1: 这个女生不回我了，杰哥你的聊天好烂啊
说话人 1: 吧，兄弟们，你们的内核要强一点，女生不回你很正常，女生凭什么要时时刻刻回你
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，真正的窗口不是她回不回你的
说话人 1: 原因是在很多浅沟通里面看的，这个时候女生回了一个表情，说不行，不会，发了一堆表情
说话人 1: 后面是学员自己在私底下聊的一些消息，因为当时我已经下班了
说话人 1: 这里他问之前男朋友没有教过你吧
说话人 1: 女生说没有
说话人 1: 其实女生是有参加这个对局的，但是这个学员他自己分辨不了
说话人 1: 接下来是很的一个行为，我必须要给这个学员指出来，非常的掉吸引，兄弟们，非常的扯淡，你们也可能会发生这样的行为，所以给我好好的记住
说话人 1: 这个学员问，他说你这两个都谈了多长时间
说话人 1: 感觉应该不长吧
说话人 1: 很明显，这个学员在问这个女生的情感经历长不长，但是这个女生她做了一个骚操作，她说 10 厘米左右吧，好像，这明显是女生想要去聊骚，想要去升级一个关系
说话人 1: 但是这个学员当时把我给震惊了，他居然说我问的是时间，不是下面的长度
说话人 1: 吧，其实我很想说，兄弟，你知道他的时间有什么卵用呢
说话人 1: 你知道他们谈的时间，谈了几年，谈了多少有什么卵用呢
说话人 1: 你分不清重点吗
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 然后这个女生
说话人 1: 他还不依不饶，他还继续的去进入这样的一个性氛围，这是我也比较震惊的一点
说话人 1: 这个女生说，哦，不到半个小时，他太虚了，就做过两次，他不行，我就没和他做
说话人 1: 很明显这个女生有很强烈的新需求，但是这个学员明显没有察觉到
说话人 1: 但是有一点，经过女生的带动，经过女生的带领，这个学员知道了这个女生是想要聊那个时间，所以说他说另一个呢
说话人 1: 这个时候这个学员才进入到了时间这个话题
说话人 1: 这个女生说没和他做过，发了一个吃瓜的表情
说话人 1: 学员还在那里聊很多无聊的话题，他说因为时间短就分了
说话人 1: 女生说不是
说话人 1: 看到没有
说话人 1: 学员还在那里扯什么情感经历，扯什么蛋
说话人 1: 这样的操作其实是会拉长一个收尾的一个时间的
说话人 1: 如果说你聊了太多这样的一个无聊的话题，女人会觉得你这个人不够性感，会觉得你这个人非常的像处男，非常的呆
说话人 1: 那么到了一定的时间，她会收回她的骚操作，就彻底成了朋友了
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 很多时候兄弟们，都是这样失去女神的
说话人 1: 你们不是没有吸引到女神，你们是不知道怎么把这个吸引给她变现，知道吗
说话人 1: 这个时候我上线开始给她聊，女生说别的原因，她给我绿了，找别人了，发了一个吃瓜的表情
说话人 1: 兄弟们，我在这里面找到一个非常骚的话题，我说那不是更刺激吗
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是在这个女生脑子里面放出一个超级短期的一个画面，就是她当一个绿奴，或者说她跟这个男的找的人3P
说话人 1: 这样的一个画面，给这个女的种植上，让她知道你是一个非常短期的人
说话人 1: 接下来这个女生说了一句非常重要的信息，我把她给记住了
说话人 1: 这个要去及时的发现，兄弟们，这个非常的重要，一些重要的信息
说话人 1: 就是这个女生说，她说我本来没当回事，有一次我发现了，她发现她的前
说话人 1: 前男友跟别人搞了，她说她主动和我分的手，我也不好意思挽留，就同意了
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是这个女生她觉得被绿了无所谓，她还可以继续搞
说话人 1: 这代表什么
说话人 1: 这代表这个女生非常强的短期属性，她甚至觉得被绿了无所谓
说话人 1: 这个时候我立刻给到一个副狗，消除她的评判
说话人 1: 我说你的包容性算是我遇到比较强的，知道吗
说话人 1: 就是我把她的骚，就是你们理解的骚，一些转换为包容性这样的一个褒义词，这会让女人觉得你跟她是同一个阵营，她才会跟你
说话人 1: 上方知道吗
说话人 1: 消除评判，兄弟们
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说我又不和他结婚，也不想和他多处几年，想那么多干嘛
说话人 1: 和他分了，我再找个呗
说话人 1: 兄弟们可以看出这段话，女生的潜台词就是想玩玩，就是想爽一下，跟这个男的搞一下，做一下，对吧
说话人 1: 跟她的前男友，她其实对性方面非常的随便的，这点可以明确的去看出短期属性
说话人 1: 这个兄弟他也看出来了，他说杰哥你看这有短期属性吗
说话人 1: 其实我想说，我在最开始的对局就已经看出短期属性了，在什么地方
说话人 1: 就是在我发我不喜
说话人 1: 喜欢乖的，我不喜欢太乖的，我不喜欢太听话的女生的时候，这个女生没有明显的负反馈，在这个时候我就知道已经有短期属性了，只是后面我再把这个短期属性给它撕大，把这个窗口给它撕大而已
说话人 1: 但是这个兄弟他不够灵敏，他到了这个时候才发现
说话人 1: 兄弟们，如果说聊到这种情况你才发现，那其实你根本就不能聊到这种情况，知道吧
说话人 1: 所以说你们必须要灵敏一点，你们才能获得短期关系，获得快速的一个短期关系，不要被女人带领了，女人带领你可遇不可求
说话人 1: 自己要去创造机会
说话人 1: 这个时候我给出了一个绝杀，我说你确实算是一个合格的跑友，值得欣赏的女人
说话人 1: 我又消除了评判系统，我又定了一个游戏规则
说话人 1: 但是这个兄弟他肯定是不敢发这样的话的，因为太过于露，太过于让他感觉担惊受怕
说话人 1: 我告诉你，这是安全的，因为我知道能在这个时候做这样的操作，仅此而已
说话人 1: 当时是这个女生回复太快了，她回了一个吃瓜表情
说话人 1: OK，这个暂且这两个回合当成一个回合来看，就把那个吃瓜表情给忽略了
说话人 1: 这个时候女生又回了一个吃瓜，回了一句语音，她说怎么说
说话人 1: 真的，很多时候你们都看不懂这是什么意思，你们可能觉得女生好像不太开心，女生好像有点抗拒
说话人 1: 我告诉你们，这是一个正反馈，因为她没有明显抗拒这个东西，同时还好奇的问怎么说，知道吗
说话人 1: 你们到了这个时候，万一突然怂了，万一去解释了，那就 game over，知道吗
说话人 1: 非常的凶险，别以为这个聊天很容易，因为已经推进到了这样深的程度了，容错率就非常的低，所以说我们一定要谨慎
说话人 1: 这时候我又消除了一个评判，我说你自由，不受道德拘束的一个感觉
说话人 1: 这个女生回哈哈哈，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是她已经接受了这样的一个复购，这是一个非常正向的反馈
说话人 1: 这个时候我们不要他们的又被这样的消息给，这个时候你们的社交直觉已经不够用了，知道吗
说话人 1: 很早的时候你们社交的直，你们的社交直觉已经不够用了，这个哈哈哈你们可能又认为是一句负反馈，再他们的再转移话题，No，他只是在看你的带领性，这个时候不要怂，继续的进攻
说话人 1: 这个时候我说你觉得我呢
说话人 1: 就是让他觉得我是一个什么样的人
说话人 1: 短期还是长期
说话人 1: 这个时候我要看他的一个契合度
说话人 1: 然而这个女生他们的更直接，非常的，她说你在哪来着
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这又是一个很厉害的一个操作，女生问你在哪来着
说话人 1: 你可能以为她是问我住哪吗
说话人 1: 不，她想知道我的一个地理位置，她对我这个人感兴趣
说话人 1: 你们可能以为只是这样，然后我告诉你，这就是女人想的套路
说话人 1: 然后我直接给到一个非常的回复，我说现在来吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，换你们，我不能说敢不敢，你们
说话人 1: 能不能想到这样的一个东西
说话人 1: 你们能不能想到这个大气层
说话人 1: 好好体验一下这个对比
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说不是，没有，我想知道你的位置，看来我这方不方便
说话人 1: 女生已经在考虑什么时候去，从你那去她那要多久，她已经在考虑这样具体的问题了，这个时候就已经成功 90% 了，知道吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我直接帮这个兄弟去做一个变现的一个操作，这个也是非常，我说不要憋坏了哟
说话人 1: 试探这个女生现在要不要做，我好考虑下一步动作
说话人 1: 这个女生说你在哪
说话人 1: 这个时候她问你在哪
说话人 1: 就是需要知道你具体的一个位置，来调整一个时间的调度
说话人 1: 这个时候我就让
说话人 1: 学员把位置给他发过去，这个时候应该发位置了，不要再装逼了，兄弟们，这个时候你不要他们的又去骚，那就很扯淡，那女人就会觉得神经病
说话人 1: 接下来所有的聊天，我都让这个兄弟自己去操作，因为已经成功 99% 了，接下来让他自己去制定时间，去把这个女生给收尾了，就行了，非常的简单，对吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，看起来非常的简单，但是其实非常的复杂，你们要去判断很多的东西，你们要去做一些大胆的一些操作
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 好好的去学习这样的一个分辨短期女生，同时去做出大胆进攻的一个操作的一个魄力
说话人 1: OK，这里是他调度时间的一个聊天记录，还有当时我让他把这个给我发过来做案例的一个截图
说话人 1: OK，我们来总结一下，学员前期聊的非常的平淡，非常的像朋友之间的一个聊天，朋友框架
说话人 1: 但是简简单单的我过来操作几轮升级，就可以把女生的短期属性给挖出来，同时让自己匹配到那个位置上，促成一次收尾
说话人 1: 这是一个比较系统的结构，
说话人 1: 它中间涉及到的主要的核心能力是社交直觉，还有你敢于去做进攻，还需要去做消除评判的一个动作，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，好好的学习这次课程，非常的干
说话人 1: 想要找我代聊的兄弟们，可以加我的微信，进入群聊，免费给你代聊，帮你约出妹子
说话人 1: 加入社群，收尾妹子 1000 个
说话人 1: 我是杰森，下次再见，兄弟们